hi everyone we didn't just clap to
sink that's not why my hands are here
right
now what is going on welcome back to our
podcast got with me law oh I did it I
did it again that's two podcasts in a
row I pointed to the right you nailed it
you nailed
it a lot a lot a lot happening in the
MCU right now um we were just talking
about it before we start recording the
new book that that came out MCU the
reign of MCU a lot of stuff coming out
about that too but you know it's still
all talking
primarily about everything building up
to Secret Wars right I mean that's like
I we've talked about a few times on the
podcast the the reboot you know we
talked about is it a soft reboot a hard
reboot all this stuff it looks like it
is going to be you know a soft reboot
sounds like what's going to happen is
it's kind of like a a way to purge
what's not working or no sorry they use
the word prune
what's not working uh and keep what is
working but still I don't like to get
too ahead because we we we can talk
about the reboot a lot which is fun to
talk about and yeah so many questions
come with that right but we still have
to remember that secret Wars are still
supposed to be this gigantic right event
right that's going to be absolutely
crazy and what I just get so excited
thinking about is all the different
Heroes and
teams that are going to pop up because
like Avengers in game I remember I did
videos
like hey this is how Nova could show up
yeah yeah right because Infinity War
talked about like xandar destroyed and
like maybe the Nova Force went to one
you know what I mean like there's a lot
of different ways it could happen and I
just remember speculating about
different carers that could show up like
like uh like I thought the living
tribuna was going to show up up and then
at the end when Captain Marvel came I
thought I was Living Tribunal I was like
ah I was so excited I was like oh that's
Captain Marvel not a
cosmic so it's like thinking back like
in the realm of like
possibilities endgame was grounded
because it wasn't a big multiversal film
yeah some like time travel and stuff
like that but in a in a in a movie like
secret ORS literally anything is
possible we were talking about you know
before like could they bring Wesley
Snipes back despite all the controversy
you know everything that happened with
him like literally anything is
possible yeah I mean you have someone
you're I mean I know you and I are both
like huge X-Men
fans totally like X-Men obviously is
like top of the list in any form like I
think it'd be just cool to see them in
the MCU finally any form so even if it's
like the fox X-Men first
Class it's certainly not my favorite
right but like I already know a new team
will be coming you know what I mean so
like if it's if it's like an established
team that's fine but obviously I would
like something a little bit more like I
would say comic accurate that fits
within the mcu's kind of like Flavor are
you talking new
X-Men yeah like new like like a new new
team but that said I mean I really
loved Agents of Shield and I would love
to see you know a couple people from
that show up like I was just about to
say Quake yeah Quake like everyone like
for so like I don't even remember when
these conversations about Khloe Bennett
like returning started and didn't she
like she like took a picture with like
sea Leu recently right and everybody's
like oh what is going on like so uh man
talks about her and then I read
something dang it I can't remember who
said it one of the it might have been
Alex P from the cosmic circus talked
about about like she was supposed to be
in secret Invasion but scheduling
conflicts or something like that and you
know I don't I don't know about all that
but I think it would be really cool to
finally see some remnants of that you
know kind of come because that that's
it's actually funny a lot of there's a
lot of talk about the Marvel like
television side versus the movie side
back then you know when it was like
Netflix and then you know shows on TV
and stuff like that uh there's a pretty
decent
division between you know the movies and
that's why you know that's kind of why
like Agents of Shield kind of like got
decanonized and stuff like that which is
weird because Coulson came from you know
Coulson came from you know which is such
a mistake because they found the last
couple Seasons found a way to make it
all tie in really well um yeah but I
will say you know like in humans the
show didn't do very well no no one
really liked it however they brought
back Anson Mount for Multiverse of
Madness and it was awesome and like and
so I'm almost like can we do that with
with you know like give James Mars in a
proper Cyclops like uniform you know
what I mean or like get Nightcrawler in
the classic like swashbuckling gear and
like it doesn't have to be Allen cuming
it could be the newer kid I can't I
can't remember his name right now but
like give me more like do the same thing
you did for blackbolt but for all these
teams that might be returned well I mean
and they did it with Professor X yeah
perfect perfect yeah and I and I believe
I think and and we've I've talked about
on the channel a lot excuse me I believe
that's what we're getting is some type
of combination B basically just like the
fox X-Men are returning from what I've
heard and this isn't like let me specify
this isn't me hearing from anybody at
Marvel this is like what the Insiders
say right so what I've heard from them
um you know it's pretty much like the
main X-Men so like professor X um
Magneto and the two of them have not
been koi about it at all I think it was
like profess it was uh Patrick Stewart
after he returned as Professor X in
Multiverse amandus who was like oh yeah
me and Ian are not done with our Marvel
stuff okay yeah he's like oh that's not
the end for me and we're like oh cool
Secret Wars but that's Prett that's what
we were thinking at the time and now
we're like oh Deadpool 3 like and then
maybe Secret Wars but yeah and that
actually to that point a lot of a lot of
what I'm hearing about the X-Men
returning is for Deadpool 3 which makes
sense cuz hu Jackman Multiverse jumping
like where did he come from you know
what I mean like Fox Universe you know
but you know there's hope that that that
you know since Secret Wars is the movie
that it is and the possibilities are
what they are endless that you know they
just kind of shift on into Secret Wars
and you know they just kind of stay
there because Deadpool 3 is supposed to
go go like directly into it right so
like there's going to be a lot of movies
coming out a some movies coming out
after Deadpool 3 but Deadpool 3 is
supposed to go like right into it so
yeah James Marson needs to return I like
I we tal I don't know if we talked about
this personally before or on the podcast
but how he he has played these
characters who just like get brushed to
the side like he always loses the girl
like all this stuff and a great guy but
just never win guy but doesn't win and
I'm like he needs his time to shine like
and he and he has as an actor recently
with like Sonic and everything he's what
is it uhur duty jur duty jury duty so so
good so good like yeah and and and
honestly the movies that he's in he does
a perfect job as an actor but the
character he's so Charming his Cyclops
is so good I just need I need they just
needed to write him as a leader yeah
exactly that was and that was the big
thing that was missing with him but I
would love an opportunity for him to
like not even redeem himself I think he
did a great job given given what he was
given but it's more of like Redeeming
the character for us fans you know what
I mean especially because like someone
like Kevin Fey has been around for all
of this like superhero content from
X-Men onward right oh yeah oh yeah it's
like you know can we bring in the
Sinister Six like in in True Form you
know I mean like like I mean we kind of
got that in way Sinister five I was like
come on one more you right you are right
there I I didn't understand the stopping
I was like we already have five why do
we need to stop you could literally have
thrown Scorpion and who already exists
in that universe and I remember people
were like well Mysterio was kind of the
sixth one even though he wasn't there
physically I was like no F doesn't count
that that doesn't count Mysterio was not
in that movie at
all and it's like I don't know I think
about you know I I I didn't hate the
Fantastic Four movies with Jessica Alba
and Chris Evans growing up I love them
as a kid I was so stoked on it and then
when Silver Surfer got introduced the
only thing that like that tarnished it
was Galactic for me they went with the
ultimates route you know what I mean and
I was just like no no no I don't want
the cloud I want I want big giant man in
pink you know right exactly I need this
blue pink guy out there who's you know
his face is as big as our Earth you know
totally but here's the thing you can't
you can't have like noren rat you can't
have Silver Surfers show up because
we're gonna have a big Fantastic Four
set P or Story coming through maybe so
maybe you save those those like those
Heavy Hitters but it's also like who
else is uh I don't know there's so many
teams that you could think of there's
X-Men obviously and then Thunderbolts
are coming up I don't know if we're
going to see a different version of that
to kind of introduce the idea I don't
know it could go a lot of different ways
you said something it struck a cord with
me because like I really want to see
Doom yeah me too
but since there's probably gonna be a
new Doom yeah do they bring back the
original Doom like for Deadpool 3 for
Secret Wars I think it would be really
cool it would be cool you know one thing
that I've heard is like
there's uh there I can't I can never
remember who said anything unless I have
it in front of me but basically there's
supposed to be you know like like Daniel
Radcliffe is
supposedly in Deadpool 3 in a secret
role right yeah like and and rumor has
it that Ryan Reynolds Deadpool is kind
of G to go around to different universes
like searching for like the ultimate
Wolverine and then he's going to make a
joke that says like yeah Hugh Jackman's
The Wolverine he can't be recast right
like break the fourth wall but you
wonder who you're going to see as like
all these there wolverines right like is
Daniel Radcliffe gonna be like that
Wolverine or is he playing
like it like he could literally show up
as himself and Deadpool can make a Harry
Potter joke like is he playing Harry
Potter you know what I mean it's like so
like that's the cool thing is like for
both Deadpool 3 and Secret
Wars I I I'm almost more excited for
Deadpool 3 for the jokes that Deadpool
can make totally about you know what I
mean like oh look it's the original
X-Men crew you know it's almost like the
stakes being a little lower being like a
dead 3 makes it more exciting and
anticipate like even you saying that
like I can see rhal or Deadpool being
like it's like more boy wizard than
Berserker rage you know like it's just
like I could totally see that exactly
and then the opportunity to bring in
like all these fan casts would be really
genius because like I want Taran ederton
to be Wolverine right I think he'd be
pretty perfect yeah but then there's
also like uh Alden Aaron Reich who
played Han Solo in Solo oh right yeah I
think he's a great actor too and he
totally has the range but it's like he
kind of looks like he's kind of got like
a James marsten look he does kind of
look like James Maron actually that's
funny I didn't think about that new but
like I think that's what secret Wars
should be is like me too you know
characters that you already kind of know
even if it was like you know people may
not have seen like Iceman in the MCU but
we we all know Iceman we all know like
Sunfire like bring bring those cameos in
because this is probably the most
opportune time to get as comic Booky as
possible I mean when Juggernaut shows up
in Deadpool 2 I was just like oh my God
he's perfect yeah I I could have never
guessed that that would be so perfect
but he was they nailed it size and like
and the threat of him and they you know
they still made it feel grounded somehow
even though it's like some kids shooting
fireballs and he's ripping Deadpool in
half you know what I mean like little
baby the baby Fe oh man I'm so excited
for deadpol 3
like yeah yeah it's so good gosh it is
so good and that's why like I don't have
worries about Deadpool 3 because I feel
like Ryan Reynolds would never let that
be a bad movie and Sean Levy all right
we talked about it he's a great
Storyteller um and he can do time travel
multiversal stuff he could do like
dimensional stuff yeah and he does
comedy really well too between him Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman they're not
gonna let it be a bad movie oh no way
like I just don't I just I don't I don't
picture a universe in this Multiverse
where also for for all you sport fans
swifties out there um Ryan Reynolds Sean
Levy and he Jackman are at the the
Chiefs game right and there's all those
rumors about Taylor Swift being dazzler
that kind of like that was like a nail
in the coffin in a way you know what I
mean I was just like oh interesting that
seems like a legitimate thing like I
watch people going to theaters for the
Taylor Swift eras tour movie yeah and
I'm just like this is exactly like the
dazzler Vibe right everyone loves her
and enthralled it would be perfect for
well he's been friend because I've been
a fan of Taylor swi for like a really
long time I've been to like so many of
her concerts like over 10 W yeah like
over 10 um and she's been friends with
Ryan Reynolds and in Deadpool 2 Ryan's
wearing a shirt that has her two cats on
it Meredith and Olivia really yeah when
he's in the X mansion going around ands
his wheelchair he's wearing has her two
cat her personal cats that's so funny so
slight not Tailor Swift Cameo but
reference so like to go full on with
like dazzler totally yeah give her a
fullon role yeah yeah but going back to
what you were saying in secret Wars how
you just want to see like all these
people show up in my mind I picture like
a portal scene and the portal from
ingame and the portals are just from
other universes now at this point in
time like I would love for there to be
some type of like like like okay like in
comics there's a council of reads right
I would love for there to be something
like that where it's like you know the
heroes communicate with other universes
and then at some point it's like all
right we got the like the Kang Trio like
Avengers ass symbol from every universe
and then it's like portals come up and
then it's like boom you know Professor X
Magneto and Mars then Cyclops broom
right there and then you know Jessica
Alba comes here and then Hugh Jackman
and Deadpool come here yeah you know
like that's what I picture in my mind I
really feel like that's what they should
do yeah they of course you know have
their own plans but like who do you
picture when you think of this scene and
and everybody listening you can tell us
in the comments as well yeah or if you
know you're driving and just listening
to podcast say it out loud say it out
loud we'll hear
Universe um who do you see who do you
see like in that in this we'll call The
Secret Wars portal scene Universal
portal scene multiversal portal scene
who do you see popping now but first big
thank you to hellofresh for sponsoring
this video many of you probably know by
now that I personally use hellofresh a
lot because for me it simply makes sense
I have a pretty busy schedule in my
day-to-day life and hellofresh just
makes eating good meals s a lot easier
for me with over 40 different recipes
that I could choose from each week
hellofresh does all the shopping and
meal planning for you ingredients arrive
at your doorstep pre-portioned and ready
to cook along with pictured step-by-step
recipe cards they literally make it as
easy as it possibly could be the meals
are very quick to make and they do
include some 15minute meals as well it
takes the hassle out of meal time but it
also can save you money hellofresh is
cheaper than grocery shopping and 25%
less expensive than takeout that means
less stress of worrying about what
you're going to eat and you save money
so if interested go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping in my mind it's
very clear I see and I've seen a lot of
fan art about this I see Toby McGuire
Spider-Man totally with Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine totally and
Professor Patrick I do see J Alba to be
me too no me too absolutely and I see
Deadpool going holy crap uh Patrick
Stewart you're still alive
like like cuz dude he's like getting up
there I know I'm not ready to have that
conversation no because he's been old my
whole life you know what I mean yeah I
mean my dad was a huge trekky and he
made me watch next Generation every
single episode so I have like a really I
have like somewhat of an attachment yeah
to Professor totally or not to Prof well
yes to Professor X but to Patrick
Stewart yeah so but you know I know New
Mutants did not do well but I could see
magic Anya Taylor Joy coming because
she's such a big star she was great
though yeah I mean like highlight of of
that situation right but there's so many
X-Men movies but I think the most
impactful will always be that first
Trilogy cast you know like if if uh if
they get Kelsey grammar's beasts to show
up because I love I love him as Beast I
thought he was a great Hank McCoy I have
a I have fan casts for the future but he
was great for for what we had at the
time but then like you know you think
about the first class like I doubt we'll
we'll get like a Rebecca remain uh
coming back as Mystique but I could
almost see a Jennifer Lawrence come back
like or even like a Nicholas Holk comes
back and you have two beasts together
and you have they I think variant should
interact with each other totally I would
love that honest at home like that was a
cool thing like well they're just kind
of like talking and they're like whoa
those like the webs come out of you like
do they just come out of your wrist like
you know what I mean like stuff like
that like slight variations maybe you
know like imagine like different Iron
Man's getting together and they're like
H you're still using nanotech you know
what I mean like he's got like some
technology or something like that
they're like hey you got to try this
next time and the guy's like what did I
think of that you know what I mean or
like wait what year are you from they're
like I'm from like 3040 something he's
like I'm from like 2020 so calm down
like you know what I mean totally um I
think in that vein I think like people
from like into the spiderverse like we
should you know like if you've seen
across the spiderverse you saw like kind
of the mix of liveaction and and and
animation I'm not saying put animation
in a live action but I do think there's
there's room for having a Miles Morales
show up for having a 2099 or Gwen you
know Spidey uh sorry spider can you
um Oscar Isaac there as moonnight and
Spider-Man 299 I can imagine that and I
love that already do
that and you actually brought up
moonnight I want I want a spooky set of
people you know what I mean I want the
werewolf yeah yeah because you know
Disney announced that that new
attraction coming out with like King
Thanos and it's like a multiversal war
and it had this concept art of all these
characters I'm just like interest
like is that a tease to maybe some of
like the you know what we might be
getting in the future I don't know I
want that I you know I want uh you know
swamp not Swamp Thing Swamp Thing think
about man thing man thing sorry I want
man thing to show up and like have a
Hulk and like maybe different hulks you
know like it's just that's the that's
the dream the dream and you know I
remember I I interviewed Rob lield on a
carpet for no way home once and I was
just like how do we how do we bring all
these like Fox characters into the MCU
full on and he was just like portals to
answer that question portals portals
portals portal dead portals Wolverine
like Rob Rob leftfield said that and
very very confident about it too I'm
just like so I wonder if that's just I
mean I wonder if when what year was that
when was that that was that was no way
Holmes red carpet so 20 2019 or whenever
it came out
I yeah I don't think they would have
because I mean he's Deadpool right so
it's like he could Deadpool can show up
anywhere right right but I'm sitting
there like did he know something already
about dead at that time but that seems a
little bit I don't know I know I know
for a fact and I can't really say how I
know this because I can't say these
people's names sure but just
conversations I've had with people which
saying like red carpens and stuff like
that like I know Ryan Reynolds himself
has been working on the script for for
like like long time very very long time
like I would say pretty much since
Deadpool 2 totally yeah and so pretty
much once the fox merger like Disney
acquired you know
that Ryan got busy like and he's
uh he's run stuff by and consulted with
some people that I knew gotcha you know
what I mean like kind of like worked on
it a little bit together bounce off
ideas and stuff like that and I don't
know those intricate details but point
being I I know that he's been working on
this for a very very long time so
maybe you never know you never know yeah
maybe Rob knew then I think I think some
of the big takeaways though are like
what you said like this is an
opportunity to show variant interacting
with each other in a big way you know
give us like that Multiverse of Madness
feel and like it'll be earned by that
point we've we're dealing with a lot of
like different dimensional stuff right
now and it'll feel feel very earned um
and then you can't have the portal scene
in endgame and not try to one up it at
least in scale you have to right so you
have to get big talent you have to get
um you know multiple Spider-Man you know
like you need leard DiCaprio as
Spider-Man because that supposed to be
with like James Cameron right I was just
gonna say all the failed castings or
like CU you know like you watch The
Flash right and then they brought like
Adam West and Nick Cage was a movie that
never got made yeah yeah the Tim Burton
yeah you could you could do that
properly with the real actors and not
just
AI but like you you could do that
properly because I think Marvel has such
a great reputation in terms of like you
know star power sure and then they'll
probably have the money because it's
Disney and it's just a matter of
scheduling or getting them on a green
screen which is like all anyone's doing
any and I actually don't think the money
will be an issue not because like they
have so much money but because I don't
think it's a hard pitch it's not a hard
sell yeah like Hey we're trying to make
this movie bigger than Avengers endgame
which you know I still consider the
biggest movie of all time like they
didn't have to come back in theaters to
you know reclaim their record yeah to Al
they might have to do it one day and
people who know me know that I'm not an
avatar fan
so um I so I still like you know if
you're if you're pitching it like can
you just pop up for like a slight Cameo
you know come just one day on set let
film blah blah blah blah and you get to
be in you know the biggest movie all
time you get to play a superhero which
I'm sure is you know everybody's
childhood dream at least maybe not you
know um I don't think it's a hard thing
you know I think if they went to Leonard
DiCaprio and was like hey do you want to
play Spider-Man finally you know what I
mean like it would be really cool if
Michael Jackson was alive because he
really wanted to play Spider-Man you
know you know Leo Leo is obviously older
but it's like there's so many versions
of Spider-Man now that it's like put him
in one of the like apocalypse suits or
whatever you know like you know what I
mean like it it is about star power like
if you can get Tom Cruz to be uh Iron
Man like everyone was chatting about
like right to interact with a Rober
Downey Jr iron man varant I know you
know well and then and that's the thing
is is like if they really want it to be
one of like a perfect movie because I do
feel like that has to happen because I
feel like if it doesn't fans are going
to be like what a waste yeah yeah like
it doesn't have to have like 50 of them
but it needs to have some right then it
needs to have an impact of some sort
right like our big thing with multi
again I I keep bringing up multivers
Madness because it did drop the ball in
terms of Multiverse for for a lot of a
lot of fans because our expectations
were so freaking high that it was like
oh we're like breaking into multiversal
stuff like Loki gave us like this crazy
season finale like what's going to
happen and then to not like match that
like level of crazy in in that was was a
little disappointing still a good movie
on its own I think but it but but in
terms of Multiverse I think it was like
a tease for us like to get us ready for
Deadpool and stuff like that just like
hey this is all possible but but to your
point Sorry to your point if we feel
like that about secret Warriors it's
it's not then it's then it's a big
failure it's a big failure and so they
need that's the one thing is like they
need to do that for it to be I think a
perfect movie because I think it has a
an ability the ability to be a perfect
movie yeah two if
if if you take like the Lower Side of
casual Marvel
fans and people who might kind of be
tired of all the Marvel movies right now
you know what I
mean and all of a sudden they hear that
you know they maybe don't see it the
first day two second day third first
week but then they hear like no like
dude you have to go see this movie
there's like a billion amazing cameos
and it'll blow your mind of who you see
play that'll do it that will do it
that'll go get those people who weren't
gonna see it to go see it just for like
that one scene and like I know there's
there's conversation in in in on the
internet like especially with like
multivers of Madness and no way home
people are like a movie shouldn't be
just cameos you know like we've seen
we've seen that discussion
but this movie should honor that still
you know what I mean but it but it's
kind of about that is the thing yeah
Secret Wars was a big like a comic event
of just like who can we pull from where
you know well right and you had like
Thor core you know working for Dr D like
depending you know there's two different
stories of Secret Wars but like but but
but even if you disregard the comics and
you look at just what the MCU is
building right now it's been about
variance yeah it's literally like Loki
you know Loki is all about variance all
about variant you know Spider-Man now
way home Doctor Strange Multiverse
Madness like you know we've we've seen a
lot of variants we've seen them all look
the same we've seen them look different
you know what I mean like it's been
about variance
so
to not really bring out the big guns
with variant in the finale of it all
would
be bad like just to be very simplistic
you know it would just be bad and and to
your point and my point I I actually
think that's what the movie really is
about having all of these variants to
defeat King variant like more variant
you know so it's like I I don't know
like I feel like it's yes it's GNA be
fan service but I also feel like it's
very fitting and just and it would work
is the thing yeah yeah but we you know
MCU is not shy about fan service and
like not
CH sorry our our other our other our
other
podcast podcast came out there our K-pop
podcast but um that said I think I think
you're right like if if we're talking
Secret Wars I do want to see all those
teams it is about variance so we have to
have a bunch of those and if they don't
deliver on those aspects totally yeah
fans are going to be like me and like
and depending on how that reaction goes
or how that goes that will keep a lot of
fans or you might lose even more you
know yeah I and you know to that point I
I think even
if because like a reboot could hit
people the wrong way so if you're coming
off of a failure of what's supposed to
be the reset of some sort mov well it's
supposed to be bigger than endgame So in
theory you could say it's supposed to be
the biggest movie of all time right
um if that comes off as a failure then
the
reboot could either be very appealing to
people or hit people very poorly totally
so I think we'll see what happens with
DC I guess to get hint of that that
Dynamic you're gonna see like all the
stuff start to change like be a Batman
helmet and Wonder Woman
shield no uh ironically enough my DC
stuff's like all over there but anyways
I think I got a lot of Star Wars stuff
here but my DC corner is like off camera
do I have anything DC not not
currently I don't I mean I even got
PewDiePie up
there it's okay well we have a DC
conversation you'll have to rearrange I
have uh Darth Vader grou SOA you can't
see the stuff up here but Spider-Man
helmet and stuff anyways um all the DC
stuff there um yeah I think it I think
it needs to be what we thought
Multiverse of Madness was this needs to
be the true Multiverse of Madness right
true like that's the kind of the title
that I think this movie deserves I hope
it will deserve that title right I hope
it earns that title yeah because I mean
just the possibility of all these
characters and cameos it's just like
because it's like you know Robert Downey
Jr Scott Johansson Chris Evans like they
got to return right like they have to
right like I mean if if Kevin feig is
wrapping up this and GNA do a reboot and
it's like tribute to everything before
well then it's like yes all those X-Men
the Fantastic
Four uh you the Punisher like yeah all
you know like does Dolph show up you
know it's just bring all those people it
doesn't have to be all of them it
doesn't have to be literally every
single one right but like the big ones
and then have those variants of them as
well the Leo DiCaprio cameos uh and then
like like Emily Blunt as Black Widow
right um John krinski could come back
again as Captain
America you know Tom hson as Thor
because he wanted to you know right yeah
that would be interesting I mean that
would just be so good and I think that
would just make for an amazing movie and
yeah it's a little bit of fan service
but it's so fitting for the movie and I
think actually a necessity for the movie
but I don't know what do you all
think is it fan service do you want it
all do you who cares if it's fan service
like yeah cares and who do you want who
do you want let us know like yeah if if
you could have any actor play any
character because that is literally
possible granted you know the actor
being alive and everything like that who
would you have who would you like to see
give us your wish list of what's the
wish what are the teams and characters
and actors that you want to show up in
secret Wars because uh there's a lot of
options we can really get crazy with
this guys so I'll end we'll end it with
I'm ask you law who you what is your
what would your top one be I got to
think about
mine ah man I I feel boring because my
top ones would be like Magneto and and
Professor Xavier just because but we've
seen those before so well no I mean
sorry if you could have any actor play
any character
oh you said Emily is Black Widow and
that was a big one for me back in the
day but what was yours well this is
going into our other lives again like I
would love to see like like a K-pop Idol
show up and play yeah like a character
that I love isn't there a an X-Men named
like Luna snow or something like that
and she's literally a K-pop Idol yeah
yeah yeah so
but crap what was I H I had a thought
but I lost it but like I would love to
see like bangchan from straight kids
play Wolverine or something like that
like you know what I mean he's like
crazy ripped you know something like
that or like interesting Yi from iy
comes in and plays like Emma Frost or
something like that you know what I mean
so give me a I would like to see a Cher
young Jubilee yeah exact exactly yeah
something like that so but yeah no as a
God just just showing up she show
up as like
eternity but no that's that's actually a
really good point is that like it
doesn't it can it should also be
International Stars you know what I mean
like for sure it shouldn't just be like
who we know in in the states like like
look at Park so Jun yeah exactly like
that that's like a big like selling
point for the Marvels so it's like who
else can you utilize like that in the
MCU that's a really that's a really good
point and I'm I'm gonna have some
trouble thinking about it all right but
in the meantime because that's a hard
one that's I can't even give you answer
right but like yeah you know um
I think I I think for me as well it's
the original X-Men yeah there's
something about I want the original
X-Men and at least Jessica Alba to
return although it would be awesome if
Chris Evans returned as the Human Torch
and as Captain America would be awesome
I will also put this out there I know
everyone's thinking about it I do want
Toby back obviously as Spidey I think
that's a almost I also just want Andrew
Garfield to fight an alien and I think
this is he need to fight a Venom yeah I
think this his chance to fight an alien
so that's uh that that's like on the top
of the wish list but I think a lot of
people would agree with that yeah let us
know let us know what you want yours
let's say yours and thanks for joining
us today be sure to subscribe if you
haven't be sure to follow law nailed it
again boom pointed the right way sure
follow law put all this info down below
what is it what is your tag just go
ahead and say it out loud it's just law
J Sharma real easy that's me on like all
my social platforms so boom there you go
sure to give him a follow uh you guys
should know me so yeah if you're here
you're already no
war if you want go ahead but thanks for
joining us and we'll catch you all on
the next podcast see you
four